también hay un espacio para los deportes
en nuestro cubrimiento especial de la
Feria Internacional del Libro aquí en
Bogotá por eso estoy con Gabriela ardila
autora del libro de las patadas
historias del fútbol practicado por
mujeres en Colombia desde 1949 y Liliana
Zapata la fundadora y gerente del club
deportivo formas íntimas bienvenidas Así
es Muchas gracias muchas gracias vamos a
hablar de fútbol femenino en un año
fútbol practicado Por mujeres como me
estaba diciendo antes Gabriela Ya me vas
a explicar por qué estamos en año de
mundial femenino mundial muy especial
primer mundial con 32 selecciones vamos
a tenerlo entre julio y agosto una de
las representantes latinoamericanas que
tenemos en ese mundial es la selección
de Colombia que vuelve a un mundial
femenino y de la mano de este libro
quiero que me cuenten un poco Gabriela
Cuáles son nuestras historias que
encontraste que se remontan décadas
atrás en la historia del fútbol
platicado por mujeres en Colombia Bueno
voy a empezar con lo del fútbol
practicado por mujeres que Ya lo tenemos
pues cotidiano el fútbol como lo
conocemos hoy en día es un deporte que
tiene unas reglas unas medidas por
ejemplo del estadio
el arco el balón y esto se practica
igual sin importar quién lo practique
por eso hablamos de fútbol practicado
por mujeres de fútbol practicado por
hombres de fútbol sin género que yo sé
que entorpece un poco la forma de hablar
pero que es un llamado de atención
porque en general cuando hablamos de
fútbol la gente solamente piensa en
fútbol practicado por hombres yo que
encuentro yo encuentro historias desde
los años 40 en Colombia en 1943 hay unos
partidos en bucaramanga que entran ya en
el epílogo por eso el título es desde el
49 pero en 1943 hay partidos en
bucaramanga de mujeres jugando fútbol en
el 49 hay partidos en Cali y en
Barranquilla de mujeres jugando fútbol
hay un interés por llamar la atención al
fútbol teniendo en cuenta que el fútbol
practicado por hombres se acababa de
profesionalizar Sin embargo en los años
50 hay una búsqueda también de parte de
instituciones políticas de no permitir
que las mujeres jueguen fútbol entonces
hay como una una invisibilización pero
en 1970 hay un llamado en Cali desde la
liga vallecaucana para que se cree un
torneo hay más de 18 equipos que quieren
participar al final solamente pueden
participar tres equipos es decir hay más
de 300 Mujeres jugando fútbol entre 1971
y 1972 en Cali después tenemos las
historias narradas por las mismas
futbolistas que ya desde los años 80 es
absolutamente
imparable no hay un lugar de de donde no
hayan Mujeres jugando fútbol no hay
ningún momento en la historia donde no
haya Mujeres jugando fútbol es
interesante lo que me dices de Cali
porque hoy en día se quiere consolidar
Cali esta ciudad como la capital de la
selección femenina de fútbol de hecho
Cali este año va a ser sede de la copa
jugadores femenina cambiando un tema
yendo profundizando un poco más en el
libro quiero hablar de club deportivo
formas íntimas Cuál es la importancia de
este equipo que fundaste para el fútbol
platicado por mujeres en Colombia
la verdad es que para nosotros un
privilegio haber encontrado una empresa
privada que creyó en las mujeres
futbolistas desde hace más de 20 años el
tema es que somos unas validadoras
históricas referentes Rebeldes que hemos
hecho una historia escrita con los pies
pero con muchas dificultades pero al
mismo tiempo con muchísima dignidad y
mucha grandeza de hecho lo que pasó el
30 de octubre Yo creo que es un
resultado de una lucha de muy largo
aliento y que ese 30 de octubre en la
final de Colombia España nuestro país se
paralizó y aplaudió a las mujeres del
fútbol en un torneo FIFA algo nunca
antes visto en la historia de nuestra
federación hablamos de esa final del
mundial Sub 17 que efectivamente
paralizó este país vivimos un Boom del
fútbol femenino de fútbol platicado por
mujeres aquí en Colombia Gabriela de
todas las historias que encontraste Cuál
fue la que más te impactó te llamó la
atención estamos hablando de décadas
Pero cuál fue la que más se llamó la
atención ya sea por algo negativo o algo
positivo Uy a mí Hay muchísimas
historias que me llamaron la atención
creo que yo decir que algo del club
formas íntimas es que a los clubes de
mujeres que han formado históricamente
las futbolistas los borraron
completamente cuando se profesionalizó
el fútbol practicado por mujeres no el
club formas íntimas Ha logrado poner su
nombre y decir a nosotras no nos borran
y a mí eso me parece que es algo que
llama mucho la atención y que yo espero
que otros clubes de mujeres que han
estado formando mujeres todos estos años
también lo logran ahora por eso la
historia del club formas íntimas me
gusta mucho hay una historia en 1996
vinieron unos
estadounidenses y querían hacer una
película sobre niñas jugando fútbol
hicieron un pequeño torneo entre
Medellín Bogotá y bucaramanga el equipo
de Medellín y el equipo de bucaramanga
llegaron a un acuerdo y se van la mitad
de cada equipo a Estados Unidos a este
mundialito y esto sucede un mes después
de que al presidente del país del
momento le quitaran la para Estados
Unidos entonces a mí esa historia me
parece hermosísima y me parece que llama
mucho la atención y que muestra como
desde hace mucho tiempo se están
formando mujeres y niñas en el fútbol y
están saliendo a representar
internacionalmente esa historia A mí me
encanta vemos Que ha habido un trabajo
de muchos años atrás en el fútbol de
practicado por mujeres en Colombia
quiero que me cuentes un poco Liliana
acerca de ese proceso de formación en el
que forma siente más ha jugado un papel
clave Definitivamente hay que reconocer
en el club deportivo formas íntimas que
su filosofía es formar
jugadoras no solamente profesionales
dentro de la cancha sino también en su
formación académica y integral nosotros
Contamos con más de 350 jugadoras
permanentemente durante más de de 2022
años han pasado cientos miles de
jugadoras por nuestro Club a las que
para no para ellas Primero era el fútbol
el fútbol el fútbol y descuidan el
estudio y ahora siete años atrás Ellas
tienen la ilusión de jugar fútbol Pero
tenemos muy claro que el fútbol
profesional para las mujeres no es una
profesión con garantías en nuestro país
Entonces qué hacemos con esas niñas que
se vienen de todos esos lugares del país
con la ilusión de ser profesionales qué
quieres hacer en formas íntimas ser
profesional yo no soy capaz vamos a
canjear el estudio y vas a alternar el
estudio con tu con tu fútbol entonces
hay que decirles y canalizarles y
seducirlas con un proyecto de vida a
largo plazo que es el estudio entonces
nosotras transformamos esas Mentes de
las niñas a nivel nacional diciéndoles
listo jueguen no pierdan la ilusión y
que nadie les quite el sueño de ser
futbolistas profesionales pero
definitivamente tiene que alternar con
el estudio entonces me ha parecido muy
chévere que las jugadoras del club
deportivo formas íntimas se han vuelto
multiplicadoras y ya las mujeres saben
que tenemos que estudiar rápidamente
para terminar le pregunto a las dos les
guste lo que se vislumbra lo que ven
venir para el fútbol femenino para subir
platicado por mujeres Colombia es porque
somos muy
resilientes muy positivas unas Rebeldes
con causas nos ilusionamos siempre
queremos lo mejor pero la verdad es que
hemos avanzado muy poco hemos avanzado
muy poco desde que nació el fútbol
profesional en Colombia terminó el
fútbol aficionado de Clubes Entonces es
ahí es una situación muy ambivalente
desde el 2017 no hay torneo nacional de
Clubes a partir del 2017 un torneo
profesional que quienes hemos vivido en
la intimidad de detrás de bambalinas
sabemos que es muy difícil que no es lo
que muestran en las en la televisión
lo hemos gozado disfrutado vivido pero
también lo hemos padecido Yo estoy 100%
de acuerdo con Liliana que de la que he
aprendido muchísimo de fútbol y quiero
decir que exactamente son momentos yo
veo un panorama difícil como ha sido
esta historia que es difícil pero esta
historia para mí el resultado más grande
como más lindo que me gusta nombrar Es
que la historia practicado por mujeres
es la historia de la autoorganización de
la autogestión de La Rebeldía y así de
la existencia esperemos que sea una
situación mucho mejor para fútbol
colombiano para el fútbol en general de
latinoamérica porque fuera de Colombia
también hay muchos países en donde se
lucha día a día por conseguir ser
profesionales de verdad Gabriela Liliana
Muchas gracias recordar el libro a las
patadas historias del fútbol platicado
por mujeres en Colombia desde 1949
Muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros aquí Gracias también a ustedes
continúen aquí en Francia 24 porque la
información sigue Aquí también en
nuestro sitio web las 24.com